well more than 1400 cova cases reported
today in nevada
now that marks the third highest day
since the copit pandemic began
and brian earlier today both state and
local health officials weighed in on the
spike
joe mohler tells us what's being done to
lower the number of cases
joe cases up and down the state are on
the rise now state and local officials
say they're doing what they can to
combat this spike but they also need the
public
to do their part over the last nine
during a weekly coping 19 mitigation and
management meeting we learned the
current rate of cases
is trending up and they just continue to
increase um here you can compare
our previous peak in july and august
to the 13.8 percent positivity that
we're seeing over the last 14 days
northern nevada is seeing a bigger surge
the positivity rate for southern nevada
is around 12 percent
statewide it is around 14. 10 of our
counties as being indicated is having
elevated disease
transmission and it looks again like all
of those counties are being flagged for
a high case rate
despite cases going up locally hospitals
say they have been preparing for another
spike with feds and ppe
in clark county they will start
increasing efforts in the hard hit zip
codes such as the east side of the
valley
testing will increase with more
locations texas station is opening once
again
the health district is also changing how
they recommend approval for large
gatherings depending on cases trend
at this time our overall capacity is in
the red column
therefore we are currently not
recommending approval of large gathering
plans
misty robinson from the southern nevada
health district says they could
recommend cancellations
from 11 3 through 11 10 snhd
did recommend approval for nine large
gathering plans
um however they may be pulled back she
says just because the recommendation is
there doesn't mean
events will be cancelled it is important
to note that snhd
is not the deciding entity on any large
gathering plan
there are several agencies involved in
that decision process we can only make
recommendations based on the
public health infrastructure
and echoing what the governor said state
officials within the health department
also said that if we don't get a grip on
this spike we could see more
restrictions put in place in the future
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now